[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you killed it man i totally had her and
you blew it man uh thank you so much for
being here i understand you just flew in
from you were in new york and you were
you flew in uh to do our show how was
your trip was it okay
well it was kind of interesting i got to
sit next to the one and only tom selleck
you sat next to tom selleck
yeah yeah but we didn't say anything to
each other i was like we just sort of
sat there and i was like i'm really
tired i was gonna go i went to sleep i
got up and it was weird because it was
like
new york
or la new york and i was i was like four
hours later and i got up and my hair is
like all crazy enough you fell asleep i
fell asleep i woke up and he's still
there of course i don't know why he'd be
somewhere else but he was still there
and he was just like
looking at me i'm like hello he was
watching you sleep and i wanted to and i
wanted to like he was watching me sleep
and i wanted to like for some reason
like his mustache is so well groomed
it's like the perfect stash and i was
like i was so tempted to be like
oh he gets that all the time
that is so strange yeah and then like on
the way back here
happy endings was on like there was like
a communal tv screen on the plane and i
had woken up and then i was in like a
neck brace from season two and i was
like put the covers back up like does
anyone notice over here right not
awkward when you're uh when you're on a
plane and your show comes up it's very
awkward it's weird because i'm like do
they know that i'm sitting right here
and we're all watching this or do they
just not know i don't know i was on
i was true story i was flying on jetblue
to seattle like a bunch of years ago and
our show came up because it's it came up
during the flight show and it and that's
yeah that's me hi hi
and the show came up on the flight and i
saw the sh i didn't expect it and the
show came up and i saw i'm sitting back
here and i saw a bunch of people like
turn around like hey
and then it's the show from just a
couple of hours ago because we just
taped at new york and they're like hey
and they all put on their headsets like
i'm going to watch this what did you do
well i started to think oh my god the
monologue how was it how did it go how
did it go how'd it go and then i thought
i think the first joke was okay yeah i
remember the first joke being okay and
so i see me talking yeah because i don't
have the headphones on and then i see me
say something and and the people in the
on the airplane just kind of went like
and they turned to me and they did that
yeah but then great because i got
nothing yeah well then the second thing
is i do the second trick and i'm like i
remember i think i had trouble with the
second joke no i see me going like this
and then go like that and no one on the
plane moves
and then one guy turned around and went
no i'm like this now this for an entire
flight no
i did i was looking for laughs
but um we there was a couple chuckles
but i couldn't see it's so sad when you
it brings out your neediness yeah cause
you're like please laugh yeah rain
please laugh please